We don't think Israel
should be allowed to participate
in Eurovision this year
Why?
“The fact that countries
that place themselves
above humanitarian law
are welcomed to participate
in international cultural events
trivialises violations
of international law
and makes the suffering
of the victims invisible”
Well, we've decided
not to exclude Israel
because Eurovision is apolitical
and it's a contest
between public service broadcasters,
not states
But you banned Russia
two years ago?
Yeah, because it
“would bring the competition into disrepute”
And you also banned
Belarus in 2021?
Yeah, because their
public broadcaster violated
our press freedom rules
And you don't think
allowing Israel to
participate this year
“would bring the competition into disrepute”?
We just said
Eurovision is apolitical
Okay, let's start again…